good morning ladies and gentlemen on
behalf of the consits the institute for
research in the modern history of Poland
I am delighted to welcome you to the
first conference organized by the
physics Institute and the Polish Studies
program of the University of Columbia
our gratitude is given to the Senate of
the polish Republic and the semper
paulownia foundation the Warsaw for
their support of this important event we
thank professor of theater abundance
planning and organizing the conference
and professor John as meat scale for his
expert help in this endeavor we
gratefully welcome the distinguished
scholars taking part in today's
proceedings more on this from Professor
meats go to whom I now turn it over the
meeting
thank you yes good morning everybody
Dean dobra as I look around the room I
realized that this conference could
probably be done almost in Polish there
are only a few people that I see whose
polish is not that good or perhaps maybe
even non-existent but we will proceed in
English just in case you're interested I
welcome all of you here from from Canada
from Poland from various parts of the
United States including places as far
away as Fairfield County in Connecticut
and I'm very happy to see friendly faces
including people from the American
polish advisory council and of course
the pilsudski Institute and polish
educators with the Polish American
Congress Commission on education as well
as people who regularly visit Colombia
and participate in the events that we do
on Poland and you will be happy to know
that we do more and more of that sort of
thing we don't do it alone that is not
the smart way to proceed in today's
fast-paced world we look for partners
wherever we can that's why we're
particularly happy that the Pilsudski
Institute was eager to do this I have to
tell you that without the leadership if
you like of Professor vonda's we
probably would not be here today because
we found out of this opportunity at a
moment when it was very difficult to get
a room and make arrangements in a city
that is preparing now for Thanksgiving
and for the holiday season we are funded
this conference is funded in part by
monies that come from the Polish Senate
as mr. Ogawa said and those monies come
both to Colombia and to the Pilsudski
Institute through the semper Polonia
foundation in Warsaw Poland and I
mentioned this also because I want to
thank them but as an indication to let
you know that things are changing
not so long ago monies were going from
the United States to Poland and now
monies are coming back from Poland among
other things to support conferences like
this one at Columbia and that is an
interesting turn of events that most of
us would not have thought about say five
years ago we're happy that we're able to
do this we're particularly pleased that
there are people who are participating
who are not polish not of Polish descent
so we have colleagues from the Ukrainian
community we have colleagues from the
lithuanian community who were kind
enough to overlook general israeli
agofsky's occupation of Vilno in the
period after World War one and opted to
help us do this anyhow
and we're very pleased that we have this
sort of cooperation both between Poland
and the United States and among our
colleagues my job is just to welcome you
and to introduce the chair and the
discussant of panel number one and that
is Professor Timothy Snyder who's
sitting next to me professor Snyder is
for male University he's a specialist of
course as most of you know on the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth and on
relations between poles and Ukrainians
and Lithuanians and he's going to be
leading this first panel which will take
about I guess an hour and a half so I
will turn it over to you Tim and let you
proceed thank you very much let me just
say that electic brief word is
introducing both of our paper givers
before they
see the first speaker will be professor
Frank Sisson who is second from my left
to his come to us from Toronto Professor
Sisson is widely acknowledged as one of
the leading if not the leading experts
on the on Ukraine and I put it this way
within and without the Commonwealth and
especially at those moments when it was
unclear whether Ukraine would be within
or without the Commonwealth press
assistant will be speaking on foreign
policy in the first Republic as will
professor on shape Nova to my immediate
left professor Nova has kindly come to
us from Cracow he is known for his
publications which connect the foreign
policy concerns of the first and second
polish Republic to international
relations theory generally and concerns
of the Polish state today so they will
speak in this order first professor
assistant and professor no luck and then
depending on what they say which will be
new to me as it is to you I will offer a
few comments at the close of the session
so further adieu professor criticism and
I think we are also chronologically
divided that is I do everything up until
part of the 18th century when Professor
Novick will take over for the 18th and
19th century as you can see this is
always unfair we who do the early period
always have to do at least 500 years 400
years and then our colleagues who come
at the end usually tell us about the
past decade or some such things so I
have to telescope this I also find that
a I regret that my colleague MJ Kaminski
is not here he frequently disagrees on
my views and I will try and present his
views in my views if not if not at
always creating creating confusion out
of this what I would like to do is
discuss particularly what I see as the
essential period for the development of
the foreign policy of the old
Commonwealth and that is the changes
that occur from the 16th century into
the 17th century now I do not dismiss
the importance of the Middle Ages but I
think all of us who deal with these
periods realize that our knowledge of
14th and 15th century polish life is
based largely on a number of chronicles
and rather scampers scanty evidence for
telling us about policy why people do
things how they defend what they do that
that information increases greatly in
the sixteenth century
and allows us I think to treat already
the statesmen of the 16th century
at times we we know them I would argue
better than we know some modern
statesmen not to speak of the current
American administration I sometimes feel
we know a lot more about our early
modern figures the delineation of
national and international and European
affairs is very much a product of the
early modern period the Treaty of
Westphalia of 1648 established an
international order and a definition of
sovereignty that provided a framework
for the emergence of the sovereign state
still the transformation of the European
order which Theodore Robb has described
as the struggle for stability was a slow
process the sixteenth century had
brought neither Habsburg domination of
Europe as a Holy Roman Empire nor out of
an extension of the DAR Islam to the
heart of Europe the conflict between the
two empires had weakened each imperial
system thereby permitting the emergence
of fully sovereign states nevertheless
the Ottoman Imperial ideology remained
intact and the Habsburg ideology adust
adjusted only slowly within Christian
Europe the 30 Years War is usually seen
as the watershed dividing the Europe in
which religious conflict could inspire
Wars and determine loyalties from the
Europe and which rulers and States
determine war and peace in accordance
with their own interests using religion
largely for the legitimization of their
activities still no sharp line can be
drawn as to when the change took place
particularly in the zones of East
Central Europe where intermixing of
religious
groups remain more pronounced the mid
17th century has been seen as the time
that the sovereign territorial state
became the major political forum but
despite the recognition of princes
rights within the Holy Roman Empire the
question of sovereignty and national
relations was still very much an open
one in Europe complex relations among
vassals protectorates and subordinate
political entities remain common in the
mid 17th century from Spain to Lavanya
from the Netherlands to Transylvania
nary Transylvania Congress of political
entities and vassal engines of rulers
and lands prevailed well into the end of
that century generally the 17th century
is seen as the time when princes and
states assume primary control of foreign
affairs limiting the activities of
powerful Lords cities and leagues
largely due to the increasing capacity
of princes and states to wage war
provincial Lords or estates could no
longer challenge their control of
external affairs and I put these all in
quotes because the question of what's
external and internal is difficult to
decide consequently the age of the
Catholic League and Valen Stein gave way
to the age of louis xiv and Lua partly
appalled the first however this
increasing control by rulers and States
over their subjects and external affairs
was far from universally recognised in
the 17th century especially in the
eastern reaches of the continent
now turning from this general discussion
to the Commonwealth the schematic view
by which we view mojo that most of the
history of the polish-lithuanian
Commonwealth is usually a brilliant in
good 16th century a troubled and varied
performance in the 17th century leading
to decline in the 18th century and you
can do this from studies of Polish
culture and its development in most
traditional schemes through political
structures and institutions of state and
I think as well this would what would be
seen
in most examinations of what might be
called foreign policy that is the
sixteenth century a century of an
expanding state relative ability to fill
various foreign policy goals effectively
and the time in which we can say that
there were a large number of major
statesmen and thinkers on what might be
called international and foreign affairs
a number of these were historians which
probably makes most of us historians
very favorable towards them
17th century seemingly one of the most
important states of Europe has
tremendous military successes early in
the century is able to project elements
of its policy and particularly its
social and cultural norms over a vast
territory internally and of course
what's internal is hard to to discuss as
well as influence societies around it
the Danubian principalities Moldavia
Valachi Transylvania then going into a
mid-century crisis caused initially by
the great voter revolt in Ukraine led by
Kemal it's key and then by the deluge
and then a period in which we can see an
increase of the power of a smaller group
of magnates decline of institutions of
states despite occasional movements
forward as well as foreign policy
quandary the rise of the Ottomans again
as a problem continued difficulties with
Sweden rise of Muscovy and I will return
to some of those and then of course our
18th century a period in which we see by
1700 as much as the wonderful professor
Garros Kiev theologian University has
tried to expand our vision of this I
still think we can see in the first half
of the 18th century many elements of
decline in the general culture and
Poland in its political institutions and
even in the existence of the polish
state under the veteran dynasty now
that's a very traditional reared view
and as I said professor Garros key and
numerous others have expanded that view
we have learned to understand the
baroque was a great period in Polish
culture we have learned to see visions
that were visions of political thought
of interest throughout the 17th century
and we have even learned to ricci some
of the elements of the early 18th
century still I would in many ways say
that much of that model
I think holes and really holds for
foreign policy and foreign policy
affairs now what can I argue in in favor
of that on the one hand the old question
we always discuss of whether we call
this a noble Commonwealth as expose
police rockets fully or not and some
people would today would question the
degree to which we have seen the
nobility as a United political class
certainly the social structure of 16th
century Poland and its influence on
political institutions they functioned
more positively than it did throughout
much of the 17th century with the growth
of the great magnates and this is the
the frequent question of wasn't a
mistake
it was the eastern expansion of the
Commonwealth of mistake since because it
because it also entailed the rise of the
great territorial magnates of the East
secondly generally we can see a
Commonwealth of these successes I have
discussed in the sixteenth century
partially because there was a certain
ability despite the livonian Wars
occasional problems on the Tatar step to
separate the problems that first the
Polish state faced and even more
difficulty after that the Polish
Lithuanian state or the Commonwealth and
in the 17th century leading up to the
deluge there was an inability to deal
with these various threats challenges
problems separately and we see this
particularly in the 1640s and 50's and
thirdly despite the attempts of
professor of weed chicken Vasilevsky and
others to tell us that Janka Demers was
not as calamitous for poland as we
thought always thought he would that and
of course the beloved sobieski always is
discussed positively I still think if we
look at the calibre of monarchs
and their ability to function within
their system there is a better structure
under Sigismund ii and even under
Sigismund the third then we see by the
end of the century so that is certain
elements of the Monarchs are more
positive now all of these can be
questioned and it would have to be
fleshed out to show some of these
examples of how the system worked in
foreign affairs it becomes very
difficult to discuss foreign affairs in
our and diplomacy in our current context
when we discuss the sixteenth
seventeenth century when many of the
institution's we are used to or just
being formed the permanent embassy is
just being created places like Venice
and the Vatican habit other states are
beginning to have it
diplomacy is beginning to be monopolized
by state institutions before that who
conducted foreign affairs was always in
question and it wasn't only in the
Commonwealth that one magnate or one
churchmen would be conducting a totally
different foreign policy the
Commonwealth is different because the
Commonwealth was not able to monopolize
its policy or takeover to degree that
other forming early modern states
surround informed on monarchs were able
to or even to have the well developed
ability of a city like a republic like
Venice to control most of the elements
of its foreign policy now I turn for
this the period that I specialized on
and to a monarch and a period that I see
as crucial for the changes in the
international situation of the
polish-lithuanian state and that is
vladislav the fourth a monarch who
usually has gotten a rather good
reputation and he seems to have been
quite an engaging person and left some
villages look positively on him but who
in many ways brought down the house in
1648 it is not so much glitz key that
attacked the polish state but it was the
polish king who attacked the polish
state or at least was seen as doing so
by many many of his contemporaries
that's an exaggeration but I will go
back to show you how in some ways it
might be argued now what are the issues
that therefore make up for foreign
policy
for a ruler like Gladys left the fourth
and this is of course the Commonwealth
at its height the map that most people
would like to see you know there's large
large what really what really changes
things first of all we should remember
who is he
he is a Vasa he comes from the ruling
dynasty not a very old dynasty but the
dynasty of Sweden and in his heart of
hearts like his father he above all is
the hereditary King of Sweden he happens
to be in the Commonwealth and the
elected monarch of that realm but he is
still struggling and hoping that he will
get his rightful domain and return to
Sweden and many times the interest of
the Commonwealth are not to come in
conflict with Sweden but the inevitably
the Vasa monarch and his Vasa relative
in Sweden are going to be at odds so we
see the division between monarch and
interests of state or interests of the
Commonwealth which play a great role
throughout this period in trying to
decide what should be paramount in
foreign policy well others laugh was not
very happy as an elected monarch we may
discuss how effective or uneffective
elected monarchy after 1572 would be but
we know that vladislav spends a large
amount of his time hunting for a few
little pieces on the map instead of the
big Commonwealth where he can be
hereditary ruler now we must remember
his brother young pudgy murmurs at the
end decides he's had enough and he would
rather be an abbot in a monastery in in
Paris than have the whole the whole
kingdom in his hands so we see but in
the purpose of vladislav that every
ruler of that time wants to be a
hereditary ruler it's not that that this
system had created this this monarchical
republic had created something different
we also see in his marriages the
emerging political situation of great
powers his first Habsburg marriage and
his later French marriage and the ties
that this would mean for Warsaw and
connecting Warsaw into the state system
that is would they diverge from a
traditional and rather difficult
relationship
the Hapsburgs and above all with Vienna
and trade this for a newer relation with
France but above all Vladislav has to be
called a royal adventurist and this is
why I argued he can be argued for
bringing the house down in after all was
his dream of a great war against the
Ottomans and to stamp out the Tatars
that gave Kaminski and the Cossacks
their great chance that is they did not
think up in many ways treason the King
thought up treason or treason in what
way he decided to convert ly covertly
against the will of the diet conduct
foreign policy to bring about a major
war so you had ruler in conflict with
the accepted institutions of the state
and in so doing he looked for
opportunities to do so it involved him
in a lot of secret negotiations with
Venice and here we wish we had more
documentation on them it involved him
with a new plan a plan to stamp out the
Tatars - to find a way that the Tatars
would attack the Commonwealth so that he
could force the diet to respond using
the Cossacks and his new alliance with
Muscovy and then draw in the Ottomans
and out of this was to come not only the
conquest of new lands which the
Commonwealth was not as a political
entity in its institutions not terribly
interested in it but as well the ruler
hoped he could become an absolute
monarch or at least have a lot more
power than he had before so we see
foreign policy being used as an attempt
to change internal Commonwealth
political structures and that's the
difficulty of saying was external and
internal he used to do this he tried to
enter a new sphere remember he also was
ruler Tsar of Muscovy on one of his
titles as well and then this was a man
who had potentials all over in many ways
he was willing to come to an
accommodation with Muscovy Russia as a
way to carry on his great Ottoman war
policy and the question of whether his
policy was was faulty as
as easily Muscovy Russia underestimated
the potential threat is still in
question to this day he this inevitably
involves him with problems with the
Lithuanian part of his federated realm
because in order to come to
accommodation with Muscovy he wanted to
make some concessions on the border to
the Russians and including as well as
for the Ukrainian territories of some of
the lands of the vision of etske so mr.
Lensky was not particularly pleased
so his great plan involved all kinds of
other consequences now it did lead to
the treaty secret treaty of 1647 he
tried to subvert the institutions of
state in coming with a secret treaty
that is it was the Daiya ostensibly
agrees to one thing but the king has a
really another policy and so in this we
see the conflicting institutions of that
state he also tried to ignore the
religious realities of the Polish
Lithuanian state and here at when I
mentioned professor Kaminsky I mentioned
it because the residue Kaminsky is a
great proponent of the Union of Brest as
being quite positive from the start and
others would see that although whatever
the long-term consequences of the Union
arrest in the nineteenth and the
twentieth in the twenty-first centuries
that in its initial phases it was
neither successful for the Ukrainians
and Belarusians who entered the union in
religious and cultural terms nor was it
terribly successful for the Polish
Lithuanian state because it involved
that state in intractable religious
controversies I would say even more so
we also have to be realistic in looking
at the old Commonwealth to think however
much in the 21st century one can assume
that the civilizational model of
religion propagated by Huntingdon is an
exaggeration when we talk about the
relations of say regions of Ukraine that
in the 16th and 17th century religion
played a much greater role and the
ability of the polish state however much
it tried to bridge the problems of
religion were always in many ways of
papering over it was always a chasm
between the Orthodox world and the
Catholic world that was very hard
hard to build a state all over and of
course particularly hard with the rise
of the counter-reformation which changed
the nature of the Catholic partner in
that state and vladislav the fourth
wanted to both conduct a new union in
1647 he actually thought he could still
bring all the Orthodox into union with
Rome at the same time he was about to
launch the war using the Orthodox army
the cossacks to fight against them and
then finally it was vladislav whether he
said it or not we can never be sure that
mentioned the community you have a sword
by your side so why don't you go out use
it now what he wanted to do was to use
the cossacks as part of finding a way to
get the tatars to attack to unleash this
whole war plan but of course what he was
doing if you look at it from the point
of view of the political structure of
the polish-lithuanian state he was
siding with a non noble constituency
against the nobility for his own
purposes now there were other magnates
who also did this who were Nobles they
were oh he was not the only one I've
just brought up the ruler as as a case
in point and what he did I've tried to
argue as he activated almost all fronts
for the Polish Lithuanian state now I
think many of you have played diplomacy
I hope in time and we all know when we
get austria-hungary or Germany and we
play that board game we've got certain
problems that our colleagues who have
Britain and Russia and France don't have
right we're stuck in the middle right
well if if you conceive of this huge
Commonwealth as potentially in the
middle but not initially initially the
Commonwealth did not seem to be fully
surrounded by problems on all sides and
as I said in the 16th century it
effectively dealt with it Muscovy in the
16th century was largely outside in the
init of the European state system and it
was good for the Commonwealth to be that
way put it be that way
Sweden was not yet a problem or threat
the Ottomans have o been a long-term
problem so you had a southern problem
and in some ways a western one for the
Commonwealth what what vladislav did by
his chain of events was he united all
the Commonwealth's problems initially by
the southern problem
and then as well it's key is more and
more successful in Camille it's key runs
his own foreign policy and is trying to
get at any one time the Swedes to attack
the Commonwealth from the north and
other such ways this unleashes a whole
series of problems which are the things
worked out for the next for the next
hundred years now how then would I call
this Commonwealth as a effectiveness in
what might be called diplomacy or
foreign policy as I've said in the 16th
century we know quite a bit we have many
missions in the 16th century the
Commonwealth is sending these missions
as its formed abroad it's able to have
considerable influence in Europe it
continues to have it for a remarkably
long time period in the 17th century and
frequently as we know historically long
after the time of the internal greatness
and strength of the Empire I'm not
pulling the common with an empire but
I'm just saying empires generally they
tend to be able to project an aura of it
long after the Ottomans were in decline
people took the Ottomans seriously I
think a bit of the problem of the
Commonwealth in the 17th century is that
the the mullinski by the way says once
of them and where are those poles that I
knew before as he's defeating him these
battles but it was shocked that they
were so ineffective in the initial
phases of the struggle for a while the
Commonwealth and pretty we see the sub
yes key period I would argue as part of
this still ability to project
considerable strength largely because of
its social social structure that
Commonwealth of the 1569 is both a great
success and a great failure its
successful in most of its social models
and welding together an elite with a
certain degree of uniformity and
dedication to a certain number of
institutions but unsuccessful in other
ways I think we have a perhaps
overestimated its degree of homogeneous
Asian or ability to integrate into its
structure
after all we call younger torres de
Ville a traitor in 1655 but we should
remember that as late as 1588
when the Lithuanians came up with their
law code they neglected to mention the
existence of the Commonwealth they
didn't really want to know about it yet
for them Lithuania was still a state and
in many ways with the way nyet reasserts
itself at the end of the 17th century as
a state again and of course the Ukraine
which is the weak point of the old
Commonwealth I think because of the
social structure the inability to
understand the differing Ukrainian
social and religious structure that made
it impossible for the Polish gentry
model to fully be integrated into the
Ukrainian territories when you had an
incipient other elite the Cossacks and
then the counter information I mean it
is we may go back and forth in
discussing I don't want to overestimate
as the 19th century did the influence of
the Jesuits had changing all mindsets
but the mindset of the commonwealth of
the second half of the 17th century is a
long way from the polish toleration of
the 16th century and in that the
Commonwealth has problems
institutionally there were a number of
issues the Commonwealth could never
succeed in overcoming union of Lublin is
really quite wonderful we we all assume
and I think in many ways it was it was
effective it worked some of the
Lithuanian all of Arc's where our
magnates were not particularly pleased
that the lose at loss of territories but
to a considerable degree is an
interesting real union that occurs
between two states but when we look at
the Saxon relationship with the
Commonwealth in the early 18th century
when indeed Warsaw virtually stops being
the center of Foreign Affairs and more
and more Dresden becomes the capital not
of the Commonwealth but in deciding
Foreign Affairs we see a less successful
model of how putting together rulers and
lands can work out the Commonwealth's
great problem diplomacy in the in the
17th century was all very good but you
needed an army to have the problem you
also needed a fleet I might add and they
try on that and the failure to solve the
military problem successfully despite
the great effectiveness of certain
elements in Polish military technology
and strategy and as I say for a long
period of time they're able because of
certain effectiveness of the who Tsar's
and elements of the Polish
- paper over that they're not able
really to play in the big games by 1700
in in in struggle and then the most
difficult problem it's always very hard
to say why society goes through a
certain intellectual decline or failure
to come up with those with innovative
ideas but there is definitely despite
the various attempts at reform of the
17th century a general decline going on
on a certain intellectual level and in a
bit inability of that culture culture to
bring forth new models now I realized I
have not given you an account of
diplomatic missions of all of the
intricate attempts by which all of these
problems were trial
and discussed and these went on in the
sixteenth century and in the 17th
century and in the 18th century I've
tried to present instead a broader
framework of this and the only reason I
can justify myself is after all I didn't
get a decade to talk about I got a much
longer period thank you I knew the press
isn't for a very interesting
introduction to the subject which
contains within it I think a very
fruitful tension towards I hope we will
return on one hand the dip in the the
terrible difficulty of Poland's
position that complications that resent
the ISA from the south also the inherent
complexity of polish-lithuanian
institution all the complexity on the
one hand
perhaps it's the structural problems
which bring the commonwealth down yet on
the other end the most provocative
argument within the paper at least I
found was the characterization of what
you spot the fourth perhaps the
institutions were not Indian at fault
because bloody slob the fourth was
controverting contravening these
institutions perhaps it was a matter of
bad rulers these are questions which I
hope will have the chance to pursue the
discussion but in the meantime we can
look forward to a second paper from
Professor antonova thank you very much
actually I will deal with next period in
which the Commonwealth ceased to exist
and polish political efforts were
concentrated around the problem of
reinstating Polish position as
independent player in international
policy and the very recreation of of the
Polish state but I would like to start
with the late 18th century when for the
first time in Poland not anymore at the
Commonwealth because after
after May 3rd Constitution Toland cease
to be the Commonwealth ceased to be
Commonwealth and started to call
themselves
Toland actually in those times the the
most important problems were connected
with Russian domination over polish
political body so two possibilities that
were that were theoretically to be
discussed by by Polish politicians of
that time and we can discuss them now
we're either to recreate polish room of
maneuver for Polish policy with Russian
consent or to fight against Russia for
this room of political maneuver for
Poland these two possibilities these two
options were tried in a subsequent not
only decades but almost two centuries
the the most interesting testing ground
of all these options and problems due to
the really dramatic compensation in
those years of great hopes great efforts
and even greater disappointments were
years of the so-called great same the
the latest years of the Commonwealth and
the beginning of the post partition
period actually we we can remind that
diplomacy was used as one of of keys to
open possibilities of reform during
that time actually the King initiative
Stanislav gustas tu' to forge an
alliance with Russia formal alliance
with Russia against Turkey was a pretext
to to to get Russian consent for
internal reforms in Poland this idea was
launched in 1787 during the meeting of
times well Bustos with catherine at the
second and then presented by russian
ambassador in warsaw who was favorable
to this idea stackelberg to catherine in
the late period of this the same year
Catherine didn't want to follow this
idea but he had she she had no no other
option because she she was entangled in
a real and dangerous war with Turkey
so she consented not for an alliance but
for internal reform in Poland then
during the reform during the Great same
during the following four years and
anti-russian so to speak option
prevailed with in the Polish public
opinion and then we have a very
interesting situation when the public
opinion as represented by the majority
or at least the most active part of the
great same representatives noblemen that
were that were debating over internal
reforms of the Commonwealth we're so
overwhelmed with an idea of anti-russian
I would say
options and alliances that they enforced
to some extent Prussian alliance
alliance with Prussia in march 17 19
against I would say first impressions of
the king stein Slavs are Bustos who was
much more I would say if not timorous
then at least much more much more afraid
of taking risky risky steps in polish
diplomacy he was quite aware of Russian
possibilities to crush polish so to
speak efforts of of getting independence
against Russia but nevertheless he I'm
in the king along with his diplomacy was
overwhelmed with this with this
enthusiasm of the great saying and they
took the Prussian alliance as their as
their new policy they could also look
for another option that would strengthen
polish possibilities of fight against
Russia namely to look for alliances with
two powers or X power I would say that
we're waging wars against Russia in that
time that is with Turkey and with Sweden
these two ideas were
very much on on agenda during the great
saying but still the most important
element in all those ideas of organizing
a system of alliances that would helped
Poland to regain her independence
visibly Russia was England England as
the superpower of that moment that could
withstand Russian Russian so to speak
pressure on Eastern Europe and help
creating a viable coalition with Prussia
or with Poland with Turkey and with
Sweden at that time and this idea was
also promoted very very actively by
Polish and boy in London Francesc
checkbook bukata and left an important
trace in Polish I would say foreign
policy imagination the main problem
however was that Poland at that time and
actually for next two centuries I would
say never played an important role in
British I would say political
imagination so only for a moment when
when Poland could be used as an element
of to some extent it could be called
diplomatic blackmail against Katherine
by William Pitt by British
foreign secretary and Prime Minister for
some time Poland was was a place of some
interest for British strategists but for
the most time a Poland had no
independent role in the British strategy
for Eastern Europe so the main problem
for Polish diplomacy at that time was to
how to persuade how to recreate this
aura that was mentioned by professor
Sisson of real possibilities of Poland
as as independent player in Eastern
Europe how to recreate this aura in in
Polish so to speak Western partners for
for this idea this problem is I would
say still with us
Western Western partners that that would
be the the best from the polish
perspective of regaining polish
independent position in Eastern Europe
never were persuaded completely that
Poland is an important and really
independent player in this place of
Europe Russia overwhelmed political
imagination of Western statement
statesmen throughout 18th century and
and further on the other option however
the option to to get Russia's consent
for Polish internal reforms and making
more I would say a room for manoeuvre
for Polish political body and polish
foreign policy had actually similar
problem as the
the opposite option namely how to
persuade Russia how to persuade Russian
political elite how to persuade Russian
Tsar or serene in this respect to treat
Poland not as a kind of an extraction
power but as a partner for this power in
Eastern European policy and this problem
was also not solved by the king and his
diplomacy prior to the great saying both
options failed actually after after the
great same took took decisive step not
only of introducing Russian alliance but
also of introducing internal reform in
May Constitution may 3rd Constitution
during this particular moment may 3rd we
can see another I would say another
example of the Polish diplomatic efforts
constant problems namely I would like to
recollect that diplomacy was used on
that very day method to influence
internally polish saying to influence
and voice to this same to accept method
Constitution there were staged rapid
reading of reports of Polish and voice
from London from Copenhagen from Turkey
and all other places where Poland had
its own voice that tried to portray the
international situation as very
dangerous for Poland
then yeah because of that asking so to
speak for a solution in in the form of
hereditary throne that was introduced in
method Constitution right after the
Constitution was was accepted insane in
order to influence say mix in turn all
foreign so to speak rebels from foreign
legacies of the Commonwealth took a
completely different position now the
international arena is clear for us for
Poland after method Constitution the
foreign so to speak context had changed
completely
so we have nothing to be afraid anymore
and both of this I would say uses of
international info in international
arena so to speak informations were not
very realistic especially the second one
was used only instrumentally to
influence so to speak so to speak
internal political arena in poland and
this met its revenge in 1792 when
catherine after after winning war
against turkey and sweden and when
France decided to to start war with
Austria just unleashed possibilities for
Russia to repress Poland this optimism
of method Constitution it was changed in
turn with with brutal reality in which
Russian alliance proved to be really
fruitless for Poland and
hectic effort by the Polish King to take
to step back to the previous idea of
pro-russian I would say orientation was
proven futile actually this last effort
of Polish diplomacy to ask to ask
Catherine for her consent to hereditary
throne in Poland but not with a Saxon
ruler but with younger hair of the
Russian throne great Duke Grand Duke
Konstantin was totally useless at that
time because Catherine wanted to
eliminate Poland at that time completely
from from the map of Europe it was too
late for Russian so to speak orientation
and Western orientation proved to be
unrealistic at that time the situation
was changed dramatically not only with
the end of of this optimistic great same
so-to-speak period but also an Russian
invasion in Poland in 1792 but also with
the French Revolution and its influence
on the general international arena in in
Europe a new and very important schism
so to speak was introduced into
international arena ideological schism
ideological drift between West versus
East West as represented by a
revolutionary France and East
represented by the most active opponent
of the revolution Catherine the Great
and successors Poland that that was
eliminated from the map tried to build
had new so to speak hopes and her new
political orientation in this situation
by choosing the West the Republican or
the revolutionary West against monarchy
cow or absolutist East at that time and
we can name the first efforts of polish
migr diplomacy as organized in
seventeen and ninety five 1719 for even
with Kosciuszko as as the representative
of this idea based on French Alliance or
French so to speak patron of the Polish
state recreation the problem was once
again similar to the previous one
presented with Western alliance Prussian
English Alliance dreamt dreamt in in
previous years the problem was that
Poland was not treated by France and
neither revolutionary nor Napoleonic as
a real partner it was used totally
instrumentally for further
years in French geopolitical contest
with Russia especially still still the
idea was supplemented the idea of of of
Leaning polish hopes polish political
hopes on Western revolutionary or
Napoleonic partner with a new completely
new idea of fighting allies in nations
not in governments but in nations that
are oppressed as the Polish nation was
oppressed by this new post partition
situation and this new idea was launched
for the first time so openly and so I
would say effectively in one of the most
important political texts in Polish
political tradition namely an anonymous
political brochure edited in 1800 triple
lots of a bitch GMO gone on afford
language whether the poles can fight
back their independence ascribed to
today's Kosciuszko secretary uses
pblicos this was a vision of poland
operating not only within the former
Commonwealth borders but inciting
revolutions in all three empires of
habsburg for insolence and Romanovs that
partitioned the Polish Lithuanian state
public Oski urged polish political
elites to launch a war of opinion
against it Saddam within the Russian
nation as well as to rise non-russian
nations with Ukrainians in the first
place against the empire that was
portrayed as the prison of nations seven
years later the same author prepared a
plan of dismemberment of Russian state
along its ethnic borders new polish
patriotism a new Polish I would say
political
she began to identify its role as a
leader of nation awakening movements in
Eastern Europe the final aim of this
role would be to crush all three empires
dominating over the region all three
participants of the Commonwealth
partitions Russia Austria and Prussia
and to make room for new actors in
political arena Nations instead of the
dynastic states and bureaucratic empires
but after the new partition that was
created by DN a-- Congress when 82% of
the pre partitioned polish Lithuanian
state territories were taken by Russia
Russia emerged as the enemy of this
project polish political project and
from that moment on this anti-russian
tendency of polish the Polish political
aims became really dominant for the next
80 years actually at least and one can
one can quote here the very essence of
this mode of thinking that that was
presented by no other person than Karl
Marx he stated in one of his articles
written in 1863 that the recreation of
Poland is the UH negation of Russia
Russian Empire and the elimination of
Russian ambitions as a world superpower
and so it was understood by the majority
of Polish I would say independence is
seeking political activists in
throughout the nineteenth century but I
would like to I would like to
enumerate here several possibilities of
realizing this scenario of diminishing
Russia's position and recreating instead
polish independent position in Eastern
Europe first to lean on Western partner
once again France as it happened during
the grant at Grand Duchy of Warsaw and
was developed further during the emigres
diplomacy after after November uprising
then once again I would like to stress
this idea of fighting Russia with
non-russian Aetna's non-russian
nationalities of Russian Empire the
fight
led by poles against against Russian
center of the system but also with
Russian neighbors endangered by Russian
expansion and once again Turkey and
Sweden maybe even Austria with sometime
endangered by Russian pants LaVista
possibilities were presented as possible
allies of this polish project of
international
system against organized against Russia
and then we have the last I would say
idea
the last option that was treated
seriously in polish migr thought
namely the general upheaval against not
Russia particularly but against so to
speak wrong order oppressive not only to
poles and non-russian nationalities but
also for Russians this idea connected
with revolutionary so to speak thought
after the French Revolution had its I
would say deep polish traditions
traditions of Polish republicanism
export so to speak export not only to
Lithuania but also to Russia as it
happened in the beginning of 17th
century I mean not poles in Kremlin in
1612 but rather great polish Lithuanian
legacy twelve years earlier presenting
an option of a union between Poland and
Russia that would give give Russia a new
political model based on polish freedoms
polish so to speak political
achievements then it was continued
throughout eighteenth century to
throughout polish
as subsequent uprisings starting with
bar a confederation through Costas Co
uprising and there was developed further
in the early 20th century when polish
socialists took over this idea in which
they they they still were not able to to
solve this problem whether it is better
to address political hopes and political
and so to speak interests of Poland
rather to non Russian partners in
Eastern Europe against Russian Center or
to address them also to Russians
themselves against the political system
of Russia against tourism treated as the
main enemy the other dilemma that was
still opened throughout the 19th century
and and and is still opened
actually his whether polish diplomacy
polish foreign policy efforts and vision
Poland as the bridge between the West
and East and the East between this
system of states based on new national
nosotros big bases and with the help of
some Western powers patrons as opened to
Russia herself or they envisioned Poland
as rather a barrier a bulwark against
Russia a bulwark or a barrier of some
Western a superpower based on some
Western superpower or several power
Western powers against Russia seen as an
alien civilization civilization alien so
to speak force that endangers the whole
structure of of Europe this this dilemma
which of the two options serves better
polish interests and which is more
realistic is still I would say opened
and in this way we can use 19th century
Poland non-existing politically Poland
as an interesting element of our
political imagination that could serve
also our contemporary discussions thank
you for those of you who came in a bit
late and I won't single anyone out of
course I'm Timothy Snyder from Yale
University and what I would like to do
in the next 10 or 15 minutes is to step
out as you see literally and
metaphorically of my role as chair and
offer a few comments on these two
presentations before I then step back
into my role as chair and open up the
floor for discussion
these have been - I think unusually
interesting papers both in their scope
but also in their provocative theses
some of which I would like to bring out
and offer comments upon I would like to
begin with the idea of sovereignty
itself a word that we take for granted
but a word which as Frank Sisson reminds
us comest only comes to mean what we
think it means in the course of the
early modern period when one person a
sovereign can start to make a plausible
claim upon total power works
power over territory it is with this
idea of sovereignty that comes our
modern notion of foreign policy as
exercised by a sovereign or by a
centralized state there is an implicit
problem here for Poland and not just in
the 19th century in the Commonwealth as
well it is it is rather unclear that
Poland at any point except perhaps in
the imagination of those who are
debating the Constitution in the late
18th century had a sovereign in the
sense that early other early modern
states had sovereigns as Frank Sisson
points out Poland's advantage and its
disadvantage and we continue debate
which was the greater was its
institutional plurality that Poland was
a Commonwealth of two nations that it
was a Commonwealth in which the nobles
played an extraordinarily important role
that it was a Commonwealth as well of
religious communities as well as
political communities which drew its tax
which through its taxes its fiscal
reserves from religious organisations
and also that this was a Commonwealth in
which there were various kinds of
affiliation one things for example of
the origins of Prussia on the baltic and
the particular autonomy which prussia
enjoyed and also what happens with
prussia later on um a related point
which Frank Sissel also raises is this
question of a dynasty in general on the
theory goes Kings would like to have
their successors also be Kings not just
because it's pleasant to have one son be
king we all have ambitions for our
children but also because then one can
imagine a future of stability one can
imagine leaving one's mark one can
imagine power tomorrow based upon
decisions today that's one problem
another problem is that because the
monarch was elected as we all know
Polish Nobles very often went out of
their way to find someone who had
no interest import because that would be
a candidate who would be relatively
neutral and therefore could win
elections such people would not
necessarily be best suited I think
intellectually to be monarch um this is
in addition to the problems which which
Frank Sisson mentions there's also the
distraction which Frank Sisson doesn't
mention that these non hereditary rulers
tended to pay a lot of attention to
gaining hereditary territories within or
without the polish-lithuanian
Commonwealth or into trying to transform
the Porsche Athenian Commonwealth into a
red eteri territory I'd like to mention
here just as a footnote that the period
of the greatest success was one when
there was de facto succession when there
was de facto a dynasty that is the
Jagiellonian period on which goes until
roughly the union of Lublin which we
haven't talked about very much but which
creates the system which then weakens
and disintegrates in the periods that we
are talking about about the agya was the
one would also like to say this and
Frank assisant mentions this as an aside
Poland does not have control of the
Baltic in quite the same way that other
European countries have control of their
sea coasts Poland also does not build a
fleet either a merchant fleet or a
military fleet when it does fight naval
wars in the Baltic it tends to hire
privateers this often doesn't turn out
very well as we all know but I would
just mention this as a kind of
alternative because Poland doesn't have
a merchant in a military fleet this
means that Poland doesn't gain the kinds
of profits from the grain trade that it
might have otherwise the poles of the
wing in Commonwealth becomes a kind of
agricultural reserve a breadbasket for
the Netherlands for Britain for other
European countries which do have fleets
also Poland misses out completely on the
Age of Exploration not intellectually
but in terms of actually having overseas
colonies for better or for worse for
having one's own trade routes in
contacts with the rest of the world all
this requires a fleet which is something
which Poland simply does not have I
would like to repeat Frank's essence
very interesting remarks which
I hope to which I hope you will return
about what is 12 the fourth that here we
have a monarch ooh on Frank's account is
both frustrated and distracted at the
same time on someone who wishes to
corrupt the institutions of the
Commonwealth and in this way brings
about so argues Frank Sisson this
terribly destructive series of war
series of wars I'd like to bring out a
point which Frank has made elsewhere in
his publications but which is very
important here one of the reasons why
what is called the fourth brings is it
is associated with this disaster with
the beginning of the end is this social
system in Ukraine I would like to make
this point in terms precisely a foreign
policy one had in Ukraine and I must
simplify here but one had in Ukraine a
fighting class which was the Cossacks
one also had an emergent ruling class
which were the magnets these two classes
were in a kind of internal conflict with
each other this was an internal
Ukrainian conflict so to speak but this
conflict meant that the Commonwealth was
not able to associate property with with
with battle which is the normal way to
do things one rewards those who fight
for you one's infantry for example as
the Cossacks were with property this
system doesn't sort itself out in a
logical way for the Commonwealth this
internal problem of the Ukrainian social
system means in my view that the
Cossacks do not become the kind of elite
military force that the Commonwealth
needed a point where I would like to
disagree slightly with Frank sis and has
to do with religion professor Sisson
speaks of a chasm between Western and
Eastern religion I think this metaphor
is probably too strong one wouldn't have
had the problems with the with the
magnets in the first place had not many
of them converted to Roman Catholicism
we know that conversions were were very
important and certainly were possible
also the union of breasts although I
agreed that it was a probably a bad idea
strategically certainly had it certainly
had its advocates most of the bishops
went along at the beginning it was a
church which continues which continued
and indeed continues to exist so what we
don't have as a chasm
don't think what we did have looking at
it from a foreign policy point of view
is an opportunity and I think one must
understand this that in that day as in
this the project of Western Christianity
was an expansive project and various
there were various formulae under which
Eastern Christians might be brought into
the larger Catholic Church thinking
about that was very intense at the time
as it has been ever since and I think
one must appreciate that religion was
seen as an opportunity not just as a
source of instability to understand what
was going on in the Commonwealth at the
time now it doesn't work out of course
but that doesn't mean that it wasn't
seen as an opportunity as indeed it
still is an aside here are a conceptual
point integration versus assimilation
these are these are characteristic a
characteristic polish debate about the
East which I think one can begin to
understand here in terms of religion is
the thing to do
visa vie the East to integrate that is
as one does after within the 1620s to
have an Orthodox Church that is within
the Commonwealth and loyal to the
Commonwealth at which for example petrol
Mahela is the most famous exemplar or
does one assimilate that is with the
Union of Brest
the Union Church and so on this dilemma
between integration and assimilation as
a way of dealing with the East continues
of course over the course of the
nineteenth and twentieth centuries to
the present day I would like to just
make the argument that what actually
ends up happening today is a kind of
integration where what is it to be
offered was not religion that was the
early modern variant which didn't work
out also not liberation that was the
19th century variant which on Jay Novak
spoke about poles offering Russians but
also others liberation visa vie Imperial
rulers that is also not successful what
is successful I think in the end is the
offer of state sovereignty the Polish
offer of something to the east works
well and I'm talking about
present-day when what is being offered
is actually sovereignty and I'll return
to that the variant um there's an
interesting point to be made here as
well
and Anansi Novik makes it about
imagination
both frank Sisson and on joy novak i
think quite correctly point out that in
the 18th century and even in the 17th
century there's a certain illusion of
Polish power partly due to sobieski
partly due just to habits both within
and without Poland and that this
imagination of great power status
precludes strategic thinking not much
was said about the 18th century and
perhaps not much ought to be but one
thing one can say about the 18th century
is that it was not characterized by a
good deal of strategic thinking on the
part of the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth this idea of imagination
comes into play of course when one is
weak when one is weak one imagines how
other people can help you which is the
kind of imagination that Andrey novak is
talking about the problem with
imagination is this
if Poland wishes to bring Britain into
Europe on Poland's side Poland must
imagine a Europe in which Poland is
going to matter more than it does now
I'm speaking of the 18th century and of
course also the present day and then
also imagine a way that this might suit
Britain's interests and then persuade
the British or whomever else it might be
that such an intervention is all going
to work out this is an inherently
complicated project however imagination
does turn out to be very important in
the 19th century in in a rather
different way there are very many Polish
successes which are imaginary by which I
don't mean that they're not real by
which I mean that they're intellectual
for example this notion of the East and
West which I think on Jay Novak himself
was suggesting um was durable it lasted
and the idea that Poland is in the West
or ever else it might be is an idea
which has found well not only total
success within Poland but also a good
deal of success for example on the east
coast of the United States on another
success if not in Russia that elsewhere
was the idea of liberation poles had a
good deal to do with
national ideas as they emerged in the
19th century and as they manifested
themselves for example in 1848 in this
sense what Professor Novak calls the war
of opinion doesn't go entirely against
Poland it doesn't benefit the Polish
state but many ideas which influenced
Europe do come out of the Polish
predicament there's one thing I would
like to add in this context which was
not raised which is the idea of carrying
out a foreign policy within another
Imperial state perhaps that's an
incoherent idea but there's something
here which at least bears mentioned
before truck courtesy goes into
immigration for example he is among
other things and others here written
about this among other things an
important advisor for education policy
for the Russian Tsar Alexander it is
charter risky who is behind for example
the Vilna education district this may
seem like a very prosaic thing but what
the Vilna education district means is
that thousands and thousands of poles
and also people who might otherwise not
have been poles are educated in the
Polish language in the Russian Empire
Adam it's Kiev it's for example is
totally inconceivable as a poet and as a
public figure without the Vilna
education district um without rigidity
acting within the Russian Empire the
polish nation I would say as we think of
it it would be would be a rather
different thing this is perhaps not
exactly foreign policy but it does raise
the question which professor Novak also
raises of partnership our poles to be
partners our foreign powers to be
partners of Poland or our foreign powers
to be partners with poles and there were
poles in the 19th century who took the
latter view that one could cooperate
with in an imperial structure and bring
about something which was good for
Poland charter this key is one when
things of course also of some of the
polls in gallaecia
after 1867 I'd like to make I'm drawing
to a close now but I'd like to make
another point about ideas and that is
the idea of an alliance the word
alliance is used throughout the two
papers and I would just like to point
out that the nature of what
Alliance would be changes enormous Lee
over the course of the period we're
talking about at the beginning and
Alliance is largely a tactical affair an
agreement to carry out a military
campaign for the most part very often
against the Ottomans by the 19th century
an alliance means something rather
different it means at the beginning of
the century a state backer for example
Napoleon a strong state which will
support polish aims which are rather
ambitious and then as the 19th century
progresses and Terra I'm just repeating
on Jay Novak an alliance may mean an
alliance with another nation that other
large groups of people will in some way
help a general liberation project which
will in turn help Poland this is of
course the direction that Polish
political thought goes in the 19th
century in various ways and it brings it
and it brings itself to another dilemma
because because of course who are the
nations in Europe are the nations in
Europe the historical nations the
nations that have States at the time
that have States in the past the Germans
the Italians the French and of course
the poles or are the nations the
population in general is perhaps Ukraine
going to be a nation are perhaps the
Jews going to be a nation and at this
level on the question of who is going to
be the nation who are we going to call
on to our side the problem of of
alliances presents itself in the 1863
uprising as we all know we're poles who
are rising up have the dilemma of
whether they should concede property for
example to their Belarusian peasants or
not um this dilemma about who is the
nation presents itself in gallaecia as
well where a Polish ruling class has a
terrible time with an increasingly
terrible time with a Ukrainian majority
population so even as polis political
thought Orient's itself towards the idea
of the nation there remains the
essentially modern problem of who that
nation is going to be and in what an
alliance would consist and I think it's
it's for this reason among others that
the great geopolitical dispute of the
late nineteenth century
is between Pilsudski and damoff ski
their various ideas about what a nation
is going to be also neither of them
simple but do mostly believing that
nations are going to be modern and
conflictual those suits keep believing
that nations are going to be associated
with historical ideas the two of them
essentially an irreconcilable difference
but both of them and here's what I would
like to conclude both of them fixated on
the idea of sovereignty each of them
imagines in his different way a Polish
state which is going to be centralized
in which is going to have sovereign
sovereign power to carry out foreign
policy triple suit ski this is a matter
of conspiracy and trusted men and a kind
of Russian Imperial tradition or a
tradition of working against Russian
imperial power for dumansky the
centralized state will be a modern state
based upon a modern society but I would
say the late 19th century on both the
right and the left is characterized by a
kind of fantasy of sovereignty a desire
to have sovereignty what happens of
course when this holy grail is attained
as a subject to the next panel so I'll
leave it at that point thank you very
much
so we have about a quarter of an hour
remaining for questions you could put
your comments in the form of a question
directed to one
that would be much appreciated position
to comment Sookie thinking of
fragmenting Russia on national basis and
being totally against Russia rather than
having that option maybe working with
opponents of the Empire and here I would
like to remind us that of one thing that
gives some spirit after simple years in
Siberian exile when he met many Russian
socialist he also exact he said Scratchy
Russian socialist and you will find the
Russian interiors Lenin said something
very similar and the stretchable should
be humid by the period of something
developing however the nature in 1920 he
did accept the cooperation and support
of Soweto it was a Russian
not totally
because he was the first you know to not
see the world started I remember it was
very itchy the positive attitude toward
advance toward the audience
the second was commanders before that
was friendship whether it was the
international language like English and
I think that we commended and trance all
the time the grants help us you the 1990
party on the Western
unfortunately then didn't help too much
physicality 39 but this was the country
that was bled to death after the World
War one and really wasn't prepared to
face this superpower which was created
by the Petersons physically think they
couldn't do too much to help us or give
the dead time everybody remember certain
height everybody was waiting when the
French - and the British group and for
the college this was ridiculous idea but
they signed the truck if the fact was
that 400 they declare the war against
the Germany so lead it would be good so
in the 39 which Fiasco but 239 and
that there was very strong relation to
different emotional and cultural a
obviously a young boy in our story at
that time in a very positive way that is
what this was any other question is in
could you please identify yourself this
is funny love each other
that
the power
those impatient agree
so I will start with this trying to
answer your question actually it it goes
back to a very well ingrained myth in
Russian political imagination and myth
dating back to the very beginning of
17th century the facts are slightly
different from this myth
the facts are that Polish army never
took Kremlin by force they were
introduced there by Russian boyars by
Moscow boyars who wanted to escape from
chaos that was created not by poles but
by the great I would say peasant and
multinational internal war in Russia at
that time Robotnik of uprising and some
elements of Polish I would say private
intervention combined with interests of
the King Sigismund assert against which
majority of Polish political opinion was
intervention in Russia at that time
deepened this chaos and so Russian
boyars Russian political elites invited
polish candidate to it to the throne of
what is well their fourth as a future
star and invited Russian sorry Polish
army to Kremlin that stayed there for
two years one of the most important
collaborators with Poland at that time
was the family of Romano's and this is
something that was totally eliminated
from Russian I would say historical
memory then the idea was developed that
all
I would say calamities were were taken
on Russia with polls and by polls by
Jesuits and polls and so on and the
memory of real social and imperial I
would say sources of this upheaval of
the early 17th century were eliminated
and so Poland was created the sole
symbol of the greatest crisis of the
russian state and it was developed
further on by russian culture by Pushkin
by Mussorgsky and other great Russian I
would say writers and composer that
established this myth as a still vivid
in Russian memory and on this myth put
in built its own agenda political agenda
you need to concentrate around me around
strict power of the sole energetic ruler
because only in this way we can we can
escape from a new smoother and new
internal chaos that our external folks
can can use I don't know if first
remember that the Russian state was in
chaos because its dynasty died out that
sort of ties to the other talk and in
the political system of that time it was
inconceivable what rule was now that's
of course in contrast to the
Commonwealth where people had concepts
with or without a monarch how it was the
second part which I think is of interest
is the Ukrainian polish cooperation
alliances are very interesting always in
their historical myths one of the first
things that happened after Ukrainian
independence was in some beer a statue
went up to heaven petrol on the service
side - knee for the cossacks who took
part in the campaign every ukrainian is
convinced in the taking of moscow
and a moment of great national pride
from which of course the polls virtually
disappear
it's very entry when interprets ones
miss later on to fit what one one needs
so and this also presents problems and
then therefore how Russian pro-russian
forces in Ukraine deal with the Cossacks
when the Cossacks are presented in this
slide of Patrol
Suhani I just would like to return for a
minute to this issue of words we use
Kasim Nam Kasim are all used for effect
what I was through well go back to the
Union of Brest for a second because I
think it also affects some of these
these polish Ukrainian polish Russian
relations that is the emphasis on
Orthodoxy in the defence of the Orthodox
Church it is often forgotten today there
was a union patriarch of Moscow for a
short time this fight patriarchy cannot
be the plans went very widely as to what
might happen but one of the reasons that
vladislav couldn't become tsar of
Muscovy was he would have had to convert
and that was an either-or decision until
you've got the union right and and the
union still would have been a little
difficult for the churches to take it
time now how great that is in how one
transfers it it proved time and time
again for every plan of putting together
Russia and Poland insuperable one of the
insuperable issues was you had to belong
to one church or the other when I
brought this up for the problems
internally in the Commonwealth I think
we have a tendency to look at those a
few elite groups who overcame these
religious barriers and divides but even
within the end of the 20th century is
very interesting in the city of review
or it evolved or Lemberg there was oh
there were always open Catholic Church
the Polish Cathedral as it's popularly
called was perfectly open during that
whole period how many good Ukrainian
Catholic units went to the Polish
Cathedral and how many of the people
went to the Orthodox churches now a
small intellectual elite who believed in
Catholicism minister
we went to the Polish Cathedral at least
perform
there's confession or sacraments
overwhelmingly the population went to
the Orthodox churches those are the same
people who know very zealously have
returned to the Ukrainian Catholic or
Union Church that is the union neither
fish nor fowl mind so to this day if
course in the 20th century this also was
the Polish Cathedral after with all of
the attendant national and other issues
were you a traitor to go to the Polish
Cathedral or were you a good Catholic
because she went there to confession but
what I would argue for the 17th century
in the 18th century we underestimate the
ritualistic that is for much of the
population in the the high points of
dogma were not of their interests much
more interest was when we were you going
to celebrate on which calendar were you
celebrating the holidays or not as to
where you went and that of course was
very difficult for calzone to overcome
we also have shifted our focus to my
knowledge st. Joseph's fact seems to
have fallen out of the Polish cults of
today he was very important in the 19th
century for Poland he has been reclaimed
reclaimed historically now by the
Ukrainians and the Union Church
so this saint of what he did with the
union of Brest now gets reinterpreted in
in varying ways as to do it the other
thing is of course the catalyst is a
ssin of Polish was only going on in the
17th century in a strange way on a mass
level that is there was a change of
religious mentality and I'm not saying
that poles were many calls were not
Catholics of Western Christian before
but it meant something very different in
the 15th and 16th century to most of the
population that what it means by the end
of the 17th century and because of this
what we might call more scrupulous or
more counter-reformation Catholicism the
possibility of bridging the religious
gap is going with receiving on the one
side because the demands are growing
from the proposal of what being a
Catholic was if in the 16th century we
find frequently all kinds of Nobles
Protestant Orthodox whatever
going from house to house pay no
attention as far as we can see to
fulfilling many of their religious
requirements by the middle of the 17th
century most many begin doing it and the
more religious these societies get in
fulfilling them the more difficult it is
to cross over from the one to the other
I might add in unless you date it's also
of interest despite the great enthusiasm
which the pregnant Catholic Church came
back and of course it has been a
remarkable restoral one-third of the
population decided to remain Orthodox so
little are great is hard to decide today
but it also shows the relationship of
those of the Eastern Church is strong a
very strong one between those two groups
to this day namely that when the
jessica's do come to boards they find a
population which is very much still
engaged where they regard as entirely
antiquated surprising painting practices
so it is very much the case that's one
of the reasons why Poland I think was
such a model of toleration why the
golden age work as it did was that
Western Christianity had not laid down
the kinds of roots which it would later
import on this larger business is quite
right we have a couple of minutes
remaining which I would like to see
Dante know about would like to make
outside Republican remarks actually I
would like to comment on this problem
that was raised both by Professor
season-ending and in professor Snyder's
commentary I think that the at the
bottom of the problem of integration
versus assimilation is exactly religious
problem that stems from the
polish-lithuanian Union
polish-lithuanian Union meant creating
the largest multi religious realm in
Europe and actually the only one so
great multi religious realm in Europe in
which Catholics or Western so to speak
Latin version of Christianity coexisted
with Eastern Orthodox group of
population so the fact is and here I
would like to a little bit to to argue
with professor system that mask OB was
already there in 14 and 15 century
although it was not so integrated into
international system it was already
there and it influenced very much the
situation in Lithuania especially and in
Polish little onion a state in general
in what way Moscow V was the sole
Eastern Orthodox country and so it could
influence it could use religion as its
lever against leverage against against
little onion and then polish Lithuanian
state so for the latter for the Polish
Lithuanian state the only way was to
integrate somehow this population in
order to withstand this growing pressure
from the religious center that could be
used against at least half of population
of the polish-lithuanian Commonwealth
and this so to speak religious religious
of Russian or master muscovite
influences in in the Polish Lithuanian
state we're a real factor a real danger
for for this state for for many
centuries so I see rest Union as an
effort to integrate however I would say
kilometers effort in its consequences
but an effort to integrate the
population of the whole polish
Lithuanian Union in one search that
could withstand this pressure from a
lien geopolitically aggressive source of
of sovereignty from Moscow be that just
reached its highest status as a separate
Patriarchate of Eastern Orthodoxy just
before the Brest Union wars was
organized and so I would like to go
finally to the point made by a professor
Qing shower actually it seems to me that
integration versus assimilation is
exactly the problem that that is that is
crucial for for this dilemma of whether
we would like to have Ukrainians be
Russians and Lithuanians as partners or
we we can imagine also Russians as
partners as long as we exclude Russians
we have to integrate somehow this
Ukrainian Belarusian and little onion
well into some I would say not only
political but cultural
unity that creates internal stresses
internal problems between polish center
of this union of this common-rail and so
to speak Ukrainian Belarusian and little
onion outskirts of this concept and only
when Russia as a separate magnet for
some parts at least of below Russia or
for all below Russia and some parts of
Ukraine seems to be an alien element
this problem of integration sees to be
so acute because there is no I would say
alien eastern border border on on which
this this clash is inevitable the
problem is that however religion is not
so important nowadays as it was in
seventeen or sixteenth century the
question is whether the political
civilization and cultural difference is
created throughout centuries by
difference of religions can be
eliminated even nowadays in our
relations with Russia can we hope for
finding at least
this contemporary Sabine cuffs that
could collaborate with us with Western
culture with with Europe I would like to
add that I was unaware of Sabine Cove
because I wrote a 600 page book yeah
thank you and just well the Union of
breasts arguments and getting them away
from Muscovy makes perfect logical sense
it has one problem there is not one
piece of documentary evidence to say
anyone thought that way in the 16th
century and the problem that I were Ruy
this is of significance is they wrote a
lot about the union of rest they
justified it in many ways and there were
many anti muscovite forces in the Polish
government and if you would put forth
that argument you would think this would
be a positive and yet no one ever says
in the sixteenth century
the reason to do this is because of
Muscovy and that's why I questioned
whether it was in their mind
I for one I'm very sure that these
issues still give rise to controversy
both historical and intellectual and I
hope you will join me in thanking
professors no balk and system for I
think a wonderful starch-based office